ni
市は
塚本と言います
コンピューターシステムの研究を20年以上やってます
あのこういうのをつけてもう14年15年目になるんですけどもこれはコンピューター
でして画面が見えてます今時計が見えてるんですね
こっちもウォッチをいっぱいつけてますね
こっちをつけています
あのウェア部生活14年ということで
あの研究の一環としてですねこういう身につけるコンピューターっていうのを
ずっとやってるんですけどもまぁあの
すぐに早くだろうと思って14年前につき始めたんですけども
意外なことに14年間孤独だったということです
ちょっともう本当にびっくりしているんですけどもやっているのはこのウェアラブル
コンピューティングウェアにエイブルつけて切ることができるということですね
コンピュータを利用すると言う
いう研究ですあの
モバイルの次のステップモバイルコンピューティングという言葉が一時期流行りました
けれどもそれはその父はコンピュータを持ち運んでいつでもどこでも使えるという
スマホがそうだと思うんですけども
このそれのさらに一歩先っていうのはほけっと中に入れるんじゃなくてもっと小さく
なったコンピューターを体につけて利用するといつでもの
でもこの生活の中で仕事の中で利用するというのがウエアラブルコンピューティング
です
これがですね14年前はそれほどポピュラーじゃなかったかもしれないんですけど最近
急に注目されるようになってきました
ここ12年ですねあのひとつは眼鏡型のコンピュータ目につける
こういうタイプのコンピュータですね後もう一つがあのこういうような売りつける
あのウォッチ型のコンピューターさらに体の
いろんな場所につけてですね色んなコンピューターっていうのがこの現れてきました
これが産業としてですね急に立ち上がるんじゃないかということが言われるようになっ
てきています
抵抗の上ダブルくるかなーこないかなーとかいうことをこういう人がいるんですけども
私の意見は
植えられるというのは必然であると
ここにコンピューターの50年以上の歴史というの上に書いてみたんですけども
最初は生まれたコンピュータっていうのは部屋いっぱいを占めるほどの大きな
コンピューターだったんですねそれを軍事計算とか科学技術計算とかすごいお金をかけ
てですねコンピューターを使ってたわけです
それが一回りサイズがちっちゃくなってでストップ財布になると企業の計算に使われる
ようになりました
企業の計算っていうのはまあその
データベース使ったり会計計算したりっということで
一昔前から見たらですねなんでそんな人でもできるようなことに媚びた使うんだという
ような話だったに違いないと思うんですね
さらにちっちゃくなったノートパソコンこれはあの
今度個人でコンピューター使うようになってその使う目的というの
は e-mail であったり
web を見たりあるいはプレゼンテーションもですねこのパソコンを使うようになっ
たとこれも一つ前から見たら何か障害ごとに見えるわけです
さらに最近はあの携帯電話スマートフォンを使ってますけども
これも使い方一体何かというのは
一つ前の時代からわかりにくい line とかですね
twitter ととかそういうなんかコミュニケーションに使うようになっていた
わけです
それってこの
前の時代から見たですねちょっとつまらないことのように見えるかもしれないです
けれど実は今やこのスマートフォンっていうのは人々にとっても一番大切なコアの道具
という風になっていると思います
それと同じようにこの操作気にですねさらにコンピューターがちっちゃくなった時体に
ずっとつけててずっと
なんか今から見るとつまらなそうに見えることに使う
んだと思いますそれが実際時代が進むとですねなくてはならないものという風になって
いくんじゃないかというのが私の意見です
米ソがコンピュータこういうふうにちっちゃくなって進化してきたんですけれども実は
ここ20年の進化っていうのは私は間違っていると思ってるんですね
人類に弊害を与えていると
コンピューターのインターネット携帯電話のせいでですね
あるいはでは一歩も外にあの家からそういう外に出なくなってきた
もしかしたらメタパとかですねそういうのもコンピューターとインターネットが進化し
たせいかもしれない
さらには
自殺とか鬱とかですねそういうものも因果関係があるんじゃないか
さらにへ
凶悪犯罪とかですねそういうものもここ20年くらいのインターネットがあまりにも
進歩してコンピュータが進歩してネット上の各部の空間っていうのが巨大になりすぎた
ために
人類はへ
進退を伴うですねじっ世界での活動っていうのをかなりしなくなっちゃって
各の空間の中に精神を吸い込まれていくという現象が起こってるんじゃないかと思い
ます
the にスマホア外にじっ世界で使うじゃないかと言われるかもしれないですけれど
も
さらに悪いことにじっ世界の中にいても
コンピューターの架空の空間の中にその人の精神活動が吸い込まれていくわけですね
あの
何人かで食事してても空を切ってでも一人だけずっとスマホしている人がいます
これってやっぱりちょっと何かよくないんじゃないかと我々はもっと信頼活動として
実績海の中で暮らすっていうのが人にとって本質的なんじゃないかというふうに思って
それに対する答えがですね皆コンピューターを3
につけてじっ世界で暮らそうと今日もたんまりつけてる人いらっしゃらないですけども
小泉んなですねこれをつけてもらうくっつけてくれるということを私は有名誌見てい
ます
ね2001年私が突き出したことです
当時コンピューターはまだ大きくでです猫新郎とパソコンをつけて
ノートパソコンの画面を興亜たまりこのあるディスプレイにまでも p たんですね
街の中でいつでもどこでもコピーが使えるぞということでこの研究開発してたんです
けども
8下の写真観ていただいた
なるように心なしか周りに人が近いはなくなるん
私のこの寂しい14年というのはこっから始まったんだという気がします
これは授業で使っているところなんですけれども授業ではもうですね最初10分間
くらいはすごくざーべくんですね
学生アレなんだアレなんだとまあ大したことに使ってないということがすぐにばれて
ですねと敬意出るとか安直を見てるとかぐらいなんですけどもまぁみんなすぐ見られる
ということが分かりました
こういう食堂なんですけども
やっぱりこう孤独感っていう
売ってあるんですねないこの味は
この食堂でこういうのをどういうのに使えるだろうなと思って
いろんなアプリケーションを作ったりでして見ながら研究を推進してきました
典型的なのがこれなんですけども上の段としたのだ2つ写真ありますけれども私の実感
としてはですね
私の前の人はみんなあっち向いていると牛した人はみんなこっち向いてるってことで
促したの人ちょっと明確したかったんですけども
目が大事かなと思っに向いてるところの写真を使わせていただい
きましたなんかこういうことを非常に感じましてですねこれを選べるっていうのは非常
に次のステップのこのコンピューター需要方法として大事だというふうに感じではいた
んですけどもやっぱりちょっと目指すっていう所が一つの面白い特徴だぞというふうに
感じました
でまぁそのどうせ目指すんだったこれをですねもっと利用しようとそれでみんなに
広めようと思ってですね
こういう学校してみません
あの犬きついあるいろんなこの方機材を体に装着してみました
また真の原因はカメラでですねこの針を撮影したり
この led のランプなんていうのはこれは光るパターンでなんかメッセージを出す
というようなシステムなんですねちょっとだけどこれは愛ですねいっぱいつけて
インパクトあるんだけども
あんまりかっこよくないかなということを反省しまして
ちょっと次のバージョンだいぶ進化します
あーすっぽりかなり気に入ってるんですけど母
なんというかメランっていうのはトータルのファッションのコーディネートだというの
に目覚めまして
髪の毛茶髪にしたりからかも入れたらいいねまりれ書いたにょので今に至ってますその
他のいろんなものも含めてですね
かっこいいコーディネートしようというのが覆ったことです
その子の周りに上の子と一緒に進めていきましょうという人が増えてきまして
いろんなプロジェクトがありました鈴鹿8耐プロジェクトっていうのはやったんです
けどもこれ続く8耐点でバイクの音あち時間のレイプなんですけれども
その中でこのウェアラブルコンピューターっていうのを使ってですね
あの監督さんがいろんな情報を見ながら
指示を行うというようなことをしたわけですまあこれがその監督さんが見ている画面な
んですけどいろんな情報が現場で見れるというのがかなりいいなというふうに思ったん
です
これ4回プロジェクトと言いましてこのこういうステージを司会をする時にここに安直
を入れたりあるいはフロアのディレクターからまあまあキーですよとか言うな情報入っ
至今ちょっと入ってこないんですけどね
そういう使い方をしました鯉使った時思ったはやっぱりで使う側がですね
かなり慣れが必要で初めて使った人は全全額使いこなせないんですけども慣れてくると
かなりうまく使いこなせるようになります
さらに医療手術のプロジェクトあの医学部の先生と一緒にですね
この周知するときに
この上の日コンピュータというのを使いましたあの
内視鏡映像とかをですねほんとはこのヘッドバッジスペルにようにしたかったんです
けども解像度がちょっと低いということと
あともし何かあのシステムが落ちたりしたら困るということでそれができなかったん
ですけれども
なんかいろんな情報これなんかフット足元の母
映像見たい方ですねあるいは
ます以下の先生なんかは患者さんの表情見たいというふうにおっしゃるんですね
そういうのにあの有用だという風に言われました
歯科医療プロジェクト歯医者さん歯医者さんで私患者なんです虫歯がおかげさんでと
いうか
たまたまかなたくさんあったんでこのプロジェクト非常に進みました
大星さんは私は高校の時の同級生なんですけども
越冬
カメラですねなんかちっちゃいカメラがあって口の中に入れて虫歯を写してくれるん
ですけどもその映像を共有しながら
間歯医者さんと患者さんがこのこれが虫歯な様みたいなインフォームドコンセントとか
言いますけどもそういうことに使いました
それからこの頭はですねちょっとああっはいいんですけども
このお腹の上にですねボタンとジョイスティックが多いであってこれであのメニュー
操作してですね
いたねとか言うを選んでくださいね
ボタンを押すとコンピューターが痛いっ
穴数ゼロコースとしたの声がなるんです
そうすると歯医者さんがここは大丈夫ですかとかいいと大丈夫とかですね
いっぱいメニューがいっぱいメニューがあるそういうので会話したということで非常に
楽しい
あの歯医者さんの
事業というのができました
こういうマナーそうプロジェクトでしてこれ去年なんですけども大阪マラソンの中で
ですねこういうメガネ型コンピューターを使って
twitter のメッセージがここに流れるようにしたんですまあ頑張って走りまし
たけど
22キロで両足が釣れましたあこれが装備がはなかったのかどうかわからないんです
けども
これが最近のまああのコンピューターちっちゃくなってきたんでなんかあんまり上田
高くが目立たなくなってきたもんですから
ウォッチもいっぱいつけてみたという状況です
問い合わせはもはその継続性とまぁ14年間孤独で頑張ってきましたけども続けてきた
おかげでいろんな
この経験を得ることができました web っていうのは使う側もですねやっぱり
ちゃんと慣れているってことは非常に大事だというふうに感じています
これは14年15年がいないか言い続けてるよ
ゲルやんですけども改めてここでん
いたいと思います1年後には町形で皆が植えられるを利用するようになると
a これは予約と言いながらちょっと皆さんへのお願いでして
お前も今回こそ実現しましょうと申し上げたいわけです
ウェアブルこれからの時代を担っていく新しいコンピューターの使い方だと思いますん
でぜひ皆でですねやってほしいというふうに思っています以上ですありがとうござい
ました
dea